this video is sponsored by Squarespace I
grew up in the American South
maybe not the heart of it but close
enough to see and experience a setting
and environment around me that I caught
closer glimpses of when my family
traveled deeper into the south a setting
and environment that is very rarely
represented in movies
[Music]
this is why I think I've been so drawn
to writer and director Jeff Nichols
filmography a native of Arkansas there's
a character that ties all of Nichols
films together and I'm not talking about
Michael Shannon although their five film
collaboration has produced some of his
best roles all of Nichols films are set
and shot in the south with the exception
of take shelter but more on that one
later
shotgun story's Nichols first film sets
up the story of a feud between broken
families in Arkansas the decay of the
area helps mirror the lack of hope for
anything better that drives the
characters towards conflict
nickels third film mud is as much named
after the setting as it is the main
character set and shot along the
Mississippi River in Arkansas the
location seeps through every pore of the
film
midnight special spans more territory
than nickels other films by placing the
climactic moments in Louisiana brings
the director back into comfortable
territory
[Music]
and finally with loving set in Virginia
near where I grew up
Nichols looks at the south not just as a
setting but as a subject bringing some
of the underlying conflicts of the
location out of the subtext and
addressing them clearly the south isn't
a favorite of Hollywood's but it's
gotten its fair share of exposure over
the years however representation of it
is limited most films have portrayed the
historic South and idealized idyllic
version in the south or an upper-class
version of the south but none of these
are the South I'm talking about Jeff
Nichols image of the south is a South
that I recognized it's a South we're
disenchanted men work manual labor jobs
where the idea of living off the land
still exists as an ideal even after
industry ization has reared its head and
then left the area in shambles it's a
South where the touch of man did not
create beautiful cities and parks but
came used the land and its inhabitants
and left scars and broken people and
we're men now abandoned by other richer
men do what they can to scrape by it's a
place with its problems but it's people
perhaps inexplicably love it they find
identity and pride in the place they
dream not of escaping but of bettering
themselves and the land where they grew
up
this south is one where a return to
nature is still revered and nickel shows
all this the beauty and the scars with
the same loving gaze there isn't a
judgment just a tenderness for the
people for the places he doesn't shy
away from the damage and the problems
but he doesn't inflate them into
caricatures or suck all the humanity out
of the setting I've seen the term
Southern gothic used to describe Nichols
films and that strikes me as a little
funny the elements present in Nichols
south if they were exaggerated could
constitute southern gothic but anyone
who describes Nichols work that way
hasn't seen how real his south is these
themes are so grounded in Nichols work
that even when he does set a story
outside the south like he did with take
shelter second film set in shot in Ohio
he still looks at the land and the
people with the same gaze I even found
Tate's shelter incorrectly included on a
list of best southern movies Ohio
becomes a facili of Nichols image of the
south differentiated only by name
Nichols uses the visual language of his
films to communicate aspects of the
setting in shotguns stories and in
loving the stillness and slowness of the
pacing communicate the slower pace of
life often shots don't move they just
rest and his films are shot mostly
outside under natural sunlight relying
heavily on nature for locations in mud
he uses the slow Steadicam movement
throughout the film to mimic the slow
flowing of the Mississippi River
reinforcing how it's at the heart of
this area and the film Nichols south
isn't a complete picture of the place
it isn't meant to be evil it's a picture
that obviously Mickle's himself is in
love with one that is clearly meaningful
to him and I think it's one that is put
forth by someone who understands the
place who themselves is a product of the
South I'm not a die-hard fan of the
South perhaps because I wasn't born
there you wouldn't have to do much to
lure me back into the north or out west
but the image of those who are rooted in
this place is one that I recognize and
one I can sympathize with and I think
it's one that's rarely understood well
enough to be portrayed accurately
I don't think Hollywood has
intentionally ignored this image of the
south it's just a matter of writing what
you know and most of them don't know
this image of the south it took someone
who understood that image to film there
and express it clearly I think this
shows the importance of localized voices
how smaller artists can represent an
area authentically in a way nobody else
has and I hope Nichols is the kind of
director we'll see more of in the future
of film thank you so much to Squarespace
for sponsoring this video
Squarespace is beautiful templates make
it easy to make a website for whatever
your needs are you just go in choose out
one of the beautiful award-winning
templates you customize it to fit your
needs whether you're making a website
for your band for a new business idea
you have for your YouTube channel
whatever your needs are Squarespace is
drop-dead simple to use and painless and
I personally love it and you can get
everything you need right there within
the platform including a domain start
your free trial today at squarespace.com
and enter offer code Thomas flight to
get 10% off your first purchase thank
you so much to everybody for watching I
really appreciate all your views and
support and feedback let me know in the
comments if there's a director who has
portrayed a certain area in a way that
particularly resonates with you if you
enjoy my videos I make follow-up blog
posts post reviews and some additional
content on my patreon and you can get
access to all that by supporting my
patreon
and I appreciate those who do so much
thanks again for watching and I'll see
you all next time